hi everyone my name is Maya Prosser and
I am thank you it's just my name and I'm
a founding team member and the head of
partnerships for a company called
lemonade which is one of the fastest
growing yay good there's one of the
fastest growing tech companies and
insurance companies in the u.s. today
and so I thought a lot about what I was
going to talk when I came here and
actually I think there are a lot of kind
of connecting webs or similar lines in
between our talks and also I'm the last
one so I hope this is good and I guess
what I thought about la something that
was kind of troubled me in the past few
months and it's kind of self-doubt or
and it's more sophisticated way the the
imposter syndrome and that's kind of the
failing that I guess a lot of us get to
have some of us more some of us less if
you're a woman a little bit more and
it's the feeling that you get that you
feel like maybe you don't deserve
everything that you have you don't
deserve you know the position that
you're in and you feel like that in any
given moment you know you might be
exposed and so kind of thinking about
you know that that that feeling that you
get and thinking about about that fear
that you know sometimes women have to
get exposed and meeting so many
successful talented women who when I
talk to them really credit a lot of
their success - I just got lucky right
and I don't know if you've had or met
women who say that but really the the
really interesting thing that I found at
that research shows that there's almost
no connection between how talented you
are
or how skillful you are - you actually
experiencing the syndrome actually the
the opposite is true the more successful
you get you you tend to feel that a
little bit more but the second thing
that research showed that it's actually
interesting is that we're not born with
it
so as kids if we all go back and
remember kind of our childhood we were
you know pretty pretty secure we feel
were kind of the greatest and almost
everything we do when we have kind of
great dreams of you know what we want to
become and and and we have that tendency
until someone tells us otherwise that
we're kind of the best thing that ever
happened to the world and my childhood
was I grew up in his room in a small
town near Jerusalem and and when I was 7
I came back home and I hit my lunch and
spilled some ketchup on my shirt it's
kind of any like a really regular day
for me and then the phone rang and I
pick up the phone and it's a casting
director for this American movie called
desperate rescue which was starring ural
Hemingway and she got my phone number
from my my you know my my principal at
school you know there's almost obviously
no data sharing information or laws in
Israel at that time and so they were
looking for blonde girls to play the
role of the daughter of of the main
actress and she said listen if you want
an addition you'll need to get in like
the next hour ten minutes away to studio
by the way also we talked to your best
friend she's coming
I like the screen it was like sure sure
no problem
got this down I hang up the phone and
then I called my best friend I said can
you come and pick me up when you're
going she says sure and then I remember
I'm seven so I I need to I need to get
approval for this right so I ID okay
who's babysitting me okay my brother so
I go to him and I'm like listen
everything's said someone's picking me
up I'll be you know I'm going addition
all good and he says sure and so I go I
get to the audition I passed the
audition it's great next stop we need to
get to Tel Aviv Hilton Tel Aviv final
audition my best friend doesn't pass so
next logical thing I attach myself to
another mom that's there with her kid
they're going I'm with you
I remember need to do the responsible
thing I called my brother again so I
listened past I Rock right good for me I
need to get to Tel Aviv someone's taking
me don't worry about it you don't need
to do anything
it means like sure and so I get to Tel
Aviv at the you know the first thing
that I remember i walking ICBC of like
blonde girls all dressed up in beautiful
dresses all comedy by their moms or dads
and this is me with my ketchup stain and
and I couldn't be happier like this was
like I was like having the best time of
my life and as I was having the best
time of my life this same time different
part of Israel my mom walks at home and
she walks so she goes up to my brother's
like hey where's your Tom my other
brother and Maya and he's just like your
time set of friends mais auditioning for
a moving in in Tel Aviv not the answer
she was expecting so my mom being my mom
she's rock star mom she finds out the
telephone gets a waiter in the hotel to
basically track me down look for a girl
that has no one and so he tracks me down
he finds me gets me to the phone I
talked to her I'm like this is great and
she's like okay never mind she lets me
play along with it the production
actually takes me back home when it's
all done and it get the part which is
really awesome so I get to like be on a
movie set for a few weeks and my
brother's punishment for letting me go
was the baby Sydney fir on the side for
the entire time so that was I was not as
fun for him so thinking about this crazy
story it is crazy but one of the things
I kind of you know try to tap into was I
was so sure of myself I had Zira block
you know zero blocks I was just going
for it I I had complete belief for
myself and my in my abilities to really
do this and I was seven which is you
know ignorant bliss but also I think
that you know it's kind of beautiful in
many ways I mean then I kind of started
thinking about okay I'm a different
person today and and and I do have that
insecurity right I do have that feeling
sometimes that I can't do everything
that I want to do or that maybe I can do
and I started thinking about these
points in life where
people start telling you telling us
right that you can't use certain things
because not only because of who you are
but because of what you are right maybe
you're not rich enough maybe you're not
strong enough maybe you're not men
enough something along those lines and
so I started thinking okay why did that
happen and you carry that insecurity
with you to the workspace and so few
years later or many years later in my
previous job not this one and we had
this huge strategic account that that
you know came in and we had to pile it
with and I was preparing to pitch to my
boss I need like I need to manage this
like this needs to be my account and I
was prepping friend it made a hundred
percent sense that I should manage it I
managed a lot of similar accounts before
there was gonna prepare me for it but
that that is security prep you know kind
of creeped in and I said maybe I'm young
and I'm not you know too mature or maybe
I'm younger maybe I'm not you know
presentable enough maybe you know I'm
not gonna do a good job you know as
women we tend to look at like a job
description if it doesn't fit a hundred
percent of like exactly what we can do
we oftentimes like okay so I can't do it
but I put all that aside and I forced
myself to stand and at least look um is
secure and I told him you know I think I
can do this and this is why and he
looked at me the same series and said
this is not happening and I was crushed
it was it was tough but a few months
later things were not going so well with
the account we were three weeks before
launch and piloting this huge pilot with
Starbucks which is a pretty big company
I'm from Israel so I didn't know um and
so things we're not going well no one is
really owning you know they account and
they needed someone to move to Boston in
the winter for three months so obviously
I became the base choice for the job and
so I took it on I didn't ask him any
questions and I took it on and I moved
myself and I made it work I hired
amazing people I made sure everything is
Matt the account is super happy we're
meeting all of our goals and I just you
know really really you know
kind of crushed it to the point where we
signed the biggest agreement that we
ever had in our company's history and
really changed you know the the future
and what we were doing as a company so
later on in that same boss called me up
a few years later asked me to be a
founding team member at lemonade is it
the right one oh not yet
and lemonade and and I was kind of his
first pick his first hire that he that
he asked during the company he's now a
mentor to me and and someone I consider
one of my good friends and so I guess
just gonna go back and circle if you
look at that chain of events it all
started with me being super insecure not
wanting to put myself there but kind of
putting that aside and and really
replacing insecurity with action and I
think that's something we need to kind
of think about it that small action we
actually started the chain event that
led me to where I'm at today and so when
we think about as women you know each
person can call it a different thing I
call the imposter syndrome call it
whatever you want just acknowledge it
that this is a baggage that you're
taking with you and then put it aside
and just really force yourself to feel
you know feel uncomfortable and feel
insecure but go after things that you
feel like that you know that you can do
that you feel like that you deserve and
when we ask for more we get more that's
just a simple equation so thank you very
much
[Applause]